well I believe that they created the
tone lay by not interfering when he
should have had reason to believe things
were headed downhill skilling and kinder
in terms of outright manipulation of the
organization I believe that it started
at the top and the poison sort of
trickled down and lay as well as a
number of the people in the Houston
Business Committee Committee community
was at least overtly religious so you
know when we talk about deep
secularizing i'm not sure what
secularizing is i mean in other words
there's someone religious if they spout
religiosity I mean in a way in the
Houston Business Committee its way of
signaling what a high quality guy you
are to my way of thinking if you wear it
on your sleeve that actually is one of
those things like you know someone being
called the financial genius that always
really worried me or I'm a good ol boy
and I say oh my god you know so I mean
someone would start quacking immediately
about how great they were at their
church and I'd start to worry because it
seems to me if you really really are
giving then it should be quiet if you're
giving us an taoiseach slee is is that
consistent with what for example Jesus
would have wanted well I doubt it